[Applause]
[Music]
92.7 wo BM so we hear that Gordon Ramsay
is here on the Jersey Shore and one of
his biggest fans wants to meet him
so Gordon if you're listening can you
make this girl's dream come true
[Music]
I'm excited to this school run I'm at
Toms River and surprise an amazing lady
she's been slightly poorly over the last
couple of years and I'm gonna surprise
with something very special
she's 12 years of age and what a great
way to supply someone on the school run
dan how are you sir matters I'm so glad
we all know that I'm so C I'm so excited
this is my oldest daughter and we
literally just ran
yeah mr. Gordon Ramsay here to see
Calista we have to the school the school
cook is here so right so how alright
yourself good good
I'm wish lights times well this she
comes with a duel that you should stand
in the corner please for you guys to
please share so my daughter could meet
her idol this fine individual over here
is actually at my daughter school and
Calista is gonna come through the door
in like a minute I'm hiding what a
lovely house an amazing family and with
three daughters of my own I understand
the pain but we're gonna stand strong
right yeah we're gonna stand strong I
can't wait to meet her nice shoes you're
gonna see a lot of tears no and what's
the favorite thing what she enjoy eating
what is she your recipes are really
blessed blessed is a master chef junior
Hell's Kitchen what do we get is she
just anything important man thank you
sir
she'll watch it just like that's my boy
let's serve her food and she goes for
teams here tell you much better okay so
I'm hiding in the Headmaster's office to
me Calista to wish her happy gym class
and I've got some amazing and macaroons
some beautiful cupcakes
so she's top obvious of age now I'm not
I'm not good on school runs and three
daughters of my own and I do one school
run a year said to be here in Toms River
in between shoots yeah pop in I'm just
absolutely panicking
in fact if the school headmaster after
see my school report in English amazing
how's Jim plows music sounds what you
playing
um we're playing actually a British song
and I was talking to my teacher and he's
like you gotta learn the Britain's
national anthem before he comes don't
say the Queen yeah extraordinary right
an amazing of them now I know you got a
tough time I know you were absolutely
under at the moment but when I see
strong young girls like you
having three daughters of my own you
know what you're inspiring now I didn't
cook these but look on you to take them
home
I was an amazing little macaroons a
beautiful cake and the most amazing
cupcakes okay so have them to take to
pack this morning that's it no be quick
otherwise we're gonna get there for 2:15
and you enjoy watching fruit brightens
right yeah oh you look out her kruger
cancer treatments watching your show
taking her mind you know welcome you are
welcome and look at that book missing
okay stay well okay continue to fight
this because you are a strong winner
remember that okay yeah we keep in touch
yes
can you voice it yeah I'll make sure it
doesn't win Mel we also nails going on
as well but that would that will explain
that that's what does it for yeah come
you next time I see okay let's have
dinner together okay you got some tough
months ahead of you but I know they're
gonna get through this and remember what
kind of inspiration you are there don't
you dare ever forget that okay
we show the same hairstyle brayer
but we're buddies now right chef buns
[Music]
[Music]
hey Johnny monk I'm here with this
gorgeous little nuggets my long-lost
sous chef I'm trying to call your work
in arm stream and I won't come round for
dinner tonight
but I've heard it's turkey meatballs now
what is it that's the bait I haven't
that was our menus yeah
what's on the menu and I know tri-tip
I've got to go to work no I know that 15
yeah a steak do you like my wife you
didn't answer the phone when the caller
what's on the dinner she didn't call me
back so
[Music]